Up first is the kill test.
Doug?
DOUG: Master bladesmiths, to
see what kind of lethal damage
your rhomphaias will do,
we will take your rhomphaia
and deliver lethal
slashes and thrusts
to this wild boar carcass.
Dwight, you're up first.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
[music playing]
Wow.
Damn.
[inaudible]
DOUG: Well, Dwight, on
the initial draw cut,
it is sharp to where
it lacerated deep
into this wild boar carcass.
On the thrust, it penetrated
easily into the carcass,
and on the final cut right
here, your blade cut all
the way through the carcass.
Overall, your
rhomphaia would kill.
Thank you.
DOUG: Good job.
All right, Billy Bob.
That's a hard act to
follow, but let's do it.
[music playing]
[sighs]
[inaudible]
DOUG: All right, Billy Bob.
It's so light, you can almost
wield it with one hand.
The edge over here is so
sharp, it lacerates easily,
without much force.
The profile you have
over here for thrusting
allowed it for a very deep
quick in-out penetration.
Overall, your
rhomphaia will kill.
Thank you.
Next up is the strength test.
Ben?
BEN: Gentlemen, to test
the strength and durability
of your blades, I'm going to
clamp them into this machine,
and it will deliver a
strike on the sugarcane
of about 500 pounds of force.
Remember, this test is all
about what the sugarcane
does to your blade,
and not what your blade
does to the sugarcane.
[sighs]
Dwight, I've already
clamped yours in.
Are you ready to go?
I'm ready.
BEN: 3, 2, 1.
Phew.
Well, Dwight, your
blade held up perfectly.
It's like it didn't
hit anything.
It's still dead straight.
Very well done.
- Thank you.
Billy Bob, you're up next.
You ready?
I can't wait.
BEN: All right.
Let's do this.
3, 2, 1.
BILLY BOB: Ah.
Kill me.
Well, Billy Bob.
I love the overall weight.
It feels like it's a
really good chopper.
And most importantly, the edge
is still as razor sharp as it
was when you brought it here.
Very well done.
Thank you, sir.
BEN: Next up is
the sharpness test.
And for that, I
give you to Dave.
DAVE: All right, gentlemen.
I'll be working my way through
this rope maze by cutting.
We've seen your blades kill.
Let's see if they've
held their edge.
Dwight, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm ready.
DAVE: All right.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right.
So Dwight, your blade
is just pristine.
I mean, there's-- there's
not a mark or a hair
hanging on it or anything.
Feel wise, it's got a
lot of forward weight.
It makes for a very strong chop,
but I do have to stop and slow
it down and back it up.
I think it's a beautiful weapon.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
All right, Billy Bob.
You ready to go?
- Let's do it.
DAVE: OK.
[music playing]
Billy Bob, this is sharp.
It blew through
rope like nothing.
I felt I could really
control this weapon,
just because it's so much
lighter up through here.
Fabulous weapon.
- Thank you.
Well done.
DOUG: Dwight, Billy Bob.
You've both done masterful work,
as expected from master smiths.
However, in this
arena of competition,
there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion,
and that champion is Billy Bob.
Congratulations, you are the
"Forged in Fire" champion.